visiblement les résidents de l'estrie et
de la beauce non pas facile les rivières
sont encore sortis de leur lit hier
alors que ces régions reçu une quantité
phénoménale de pluies les inondations à
répétition non dans ces régions qui
savait avec les changements climatiques
partout dans le monde les scientifiques
essaient de mieux prédire les zones à
risque d'inondation on en parle avec
notre journaliste scientifique renommé
nogueira gagné bonjour à nos michel
alors il ya une étude qui montre en fait
que la hausse du niveau de la mer des
mers fait pourrait toucher quoi trois
fois plus de personnes qu'on le pensait
vraiment beaucoup de gens je pense va
falloir qu'on s'habitue aux inondations
malheureusement en raison d'avoir un peu
plus au cours des prochaines années
donc une étude vraiment important qui
est parue dans nature cette semaine qui
montré que les zones à risque
d'inondation du site 2050 ça va à cause
de la montée du niveau de la mer ça va
augmenter de façon vraiment importante
déjà que les estimations assez
pessimiste avant on peut le voir sur le
tableau qui à l'écran ce moment on pas
d'ici 2050 les anciennes données tous
les ans que les anciens modèles montrer
ses compensées qui aurait 38 millions de
personnes qui les vivent dans un endroit
qui allait passer sous le niveau de la
mer d'ici 2050 et que 60 18 millions
personnes seraient victimes des
inondations annuelles on vivrait dans
des endroits où l'eau montrer de façon
périodique déjà là c'est beaucoup de
gens mais là les nouvelles données qui
sont dans l'étude qui sont parues ce qui
est une part est ce après ce que ça
ferait ce que fait x 9 x 5
on passe à 150 millions de personnes qui
vont vivre dans une région sous le
niveau de la mer d'ici 2050
donc ces gens là faut il va falloir des
digues ou des barrières pour les
protéger sinon les ça va être
complètement inondé 300 millions de
personnes qui seraient victimes
d'inondations annuel on est tous à cause
la hausse du niveau de la mer c'est des
chiffres qui sont vraiment
impressionnants donc ceci si on voit
laisser les gens qui sont affectés mais
son voient en images qu'est ce que ça
donne sur les casots son voile et les
nouvelles projections voit les cartes
d'un peu partout dans le monde à ce que
les prêts dont on voit les projections
avant donc dans les anciens de donner à
gauche de cette carte là et les
nouvelles prédictions c'est ce qu'on
voit à droite et on veut raisonnablement
ccd région qui vont passer sous le
niveau de la mer donc on a vu en vo
vietnam le sud du pays qui passait sous
l'eau en 2050 dans les images avant si
c'est la ville de mumbai qui ont des
villes les plus peuplées domingue qui
elle aussi va devoir repasser dans les
on va vous passer sous l'eau votre
victime d'inondations importantes
on voit ici alexandrie en egypte
tout ça c'est des régions bonne partie
de la détaxe c'est l'eau qui monte les
lisant les régions qui passe sous le
niveau de la mer et les inondations qui
se répète de façon importante et tout
ceci c'est ce qu'on voit dans ces
nouvelles études donc c'est vraiment la
situation vraiment pire et d'ici 2050
peu partout à travers le monde et
pourquoi on a l'impression que cette
situation va empirer
mais c'est ce soir c'est vrai que les
changements climatiques ont tendance à
s'accélérer pion est la hausse du niveau
de la mer en même temps mais dans ce cas
ci c'est plutôt un problème qu'on avec
les anciens modèles qui avait comme une
assez bonne marge d'erreur parce que à
l'international généralement la montée
du niveau de la mer on l'estiment par
des relevés satellites ont fait des
évaluations on regarde le quel est le
niveau du sol par rapport au niveau de
la mer le problème c'est que c'est ce
type de donner leur avis à venir avec
une assez grosse marge d'erreur parce
que certains dimanches satellites sont
pas capables de faire la différence
entre le niveau du sol
l'asim de certains arbres et la 6me le
toits de certains bâtiments
donc c'est une trop grande différence a
fait une assez bonne marge d'erreur de
plusieurs mètres et quand le nouveau
modèle qui est il utilisé dans cette
étude la baie utilise l'intelligence
artificielle pour diminuer cette marge
d'erreur et c'est ce qui fait qu'on a
ces nouvelles données vraiment
dramatique qu'on eut cette semaine et en
plus elles sont calculées ces données là
avec avec une hausse de température de
limiter à 2 degrés celsius
si on respecte le protocole de paris et
son voit que partout dans le monde c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on est en train de
réaliser en soi mais alors plus ça va se
réchauffer plusieurs le savoir et la
scion pire ce sera un autre sujet des
images qui ont été diffusées sur
facebook à redire amis sur facebook
cette semaine à partir d'un hôpital on
va les voir donc ces images de dallas au
texas on y voit en fait une jeune femme
en train de répondre aux questions à dix
mains jouées regarder aux questions des
médecins pendant qu'on l'opère
directement au cerveau c'est la première
fois en fait qu'on diffuse une opération
si délicate indirects
renoncer particulier les aider on voit
vraiment où on en est rendu dans la
médecine que dans les réseaux sociaux
des opérations comme si on assume
diffusé sur facebook y en a déjà eu mais
sur le cerveau c'est une première
45000 spectateurs qui sont venus
regarder comment comment l'opération se
déroulait pour la passion qui s'appelle
jenna fischer lc une étudiante en
physiothérapie de 25 ans et voulait
montrer aux autres personnes qui étaient
dans sa situation à l
comment avec eux c'est que là que leur
cas est traitable et comment ça peut le
faire donc dans ces opérations où la
passion de restent éveillés pendant
qu'on est entré mais les chirurgiens
travaillent sur son cerveau auquel elle
avait une masse le vaisseau sanguin qui
faisait qu'elle avait des crises
d'épilepsie les mains qui a perdu
l'usagé de la parole c'est une opération
que duré 4 heures 30 environ mais on en
n'a diffusé que 45 minutes et ce genre
d'opération other plus courts us et ça
c'est plus des opérations à veiller sur
cerveau c'est plus en plus courant il
existe depuis 2000 mais donc c'est si on
utilise cet étudiant fait pour guider
les chirurgies donc ici que quand on
recueille travail dans les régions qui
sont extrêmement délicate donc ici par
exemple quand même vu que c'était une
région affectée par le langage mais si
jamais les chirurgies faisait une
manoeuvre qui lui demandait de verre
exemple identifier certains mots sur un
ipad ou de discuter de différents sujets
garde contact avec le passé
on fait attention ça permet de voir un
peu plus les impacts de cette opération
si jamais vous avez besoin
un millimètre de troupes la personne on
voyait que la passion de commencer à
parler différemment au québec des
changements sont engageons savez les
chirurgies savait qu'il fallait pas
aller là donc ça ça aide a guidé les
chirurgies c'est jojo c'est la raison
pour laquelle on fait des opérations à
veiller comme ça très intéressant merci
beaucoup et non révisé